a king there's no friends only followers  and fault in a chapter of my life is  done this Prince I spent my days  drinking clowning  now I find myself the king choose your  steps wisely here brother they have  their own kingdoms behind their eyes I  need men around me I can trust  you are my friend I will come with you  now you will be wash over vinyls here  the different King France is taunting us  they were my father's enemies not mine  the screams of young men  so led me to sleep at night you will not  topple this king henry v of england you  so underestimate are you ready for  awaits us  or is bloody and slowly this is her  thesis  do you feel his sense of achievement  surrender to me  King of England are you scared already I  can feel the weight of this crown I wear  [Music]  [Music]